so
back with another terrible rap
based guards are still crazy but you
know the drill
and shout out to my fantastic mother on
this one
turn it up on that horsepower give you a
hard time roll like a hard line you
think i do it every day i do it part
time break the brakes unstoppable like
an earthquake you want to stop my remit
course please give me a break turn
around don't be so negative g but just
keep going on we ain't taking error to
the knee no none is pasture from killer
kill i would drop you so hard you're
stuck on the left hill now let me give
these beers a lesson at raping tip one
always press recording while you're
taping when you are in pain don't take
cocaine but for 20 blaze it smoke weed
every day yeah and ict is my weed so
subscribe to me to be or not to be in
the silverado
making youtube money making youtube
money making youtube money playing
roller coaster tycoon 3 and making
people see the things that i make in
this game and making them believe that i
can make reality like i'm a [ __ ]
prodigy but believe me making [ __ ] like
this for real it's [ __ ] easy finding
things that i need my name up in lights
i just want to be seen but i am
surrounded by dykes i space so hard it
could be a science fiction but i'm still
on the rail due to all the side flashing
like boomerang i always come back but i
keep serving your ass so i'm more like a
map you want to take a ride get in the
car emcee cause you're riding with the
premier coaster builder that's me
kicking in the front seat the best way
to go i may not have a front cam but i
still go bro it's not a dead mouse nor
is it a space again it's not golden or
bronze no it's a silver